to extreme impeachment hearings were
supposed to bride evidence of profound
wrongdoing instead over and over they
revealed only the thought process of
professional bureaucrats what they
assumed what their priorities are what
they told each other but that is not the
same as evidence of a crime as
congressman Mike Turner explained dr.
hill you have provided me probably the
greatest piece of evidence that's before
us to illustrate the problem with
hearsay
so you said based on questions and
statements I have heard no matter how
convinced we are dr. hill no matter how
much we believe we know that what we've
heard is true it is still just what
we've heard so Democrats had a response
to Turner they didn't produce better
evidence that would be too simple they
called him a sexist congressman Sean
Patrick baloney Maloney who was below
nothing swooped in to protect Hill
saying she had been the victim of
mansplaining dr. hill first of all I
thought that was some epic mansplaining
that you were forced to endure by my
colleague mr Turner and I'm watching as
some of us think it was inappropriate
but I appreciate I appreciate your
forbearance total mediocrity that guy is
Jimmy Bruce is not a mediocrity just the
opposite
she's one of our favorite guest shows
get Tammy Bruce on fox nation she joins
us tonight Timmy what do you what do you
make of that that was is that doesn't
really seem to be an argument it seems
maybe less than that yeah it's less than
that and what I'll do here is I'll do
some Tammy's planing to hopefully maybe
shed some light on the nature of what
happened there as you saw we had and we
know these televised hearings are meant
for the viewer right I mean this is the
one chance for the Republicans to try to
explain what the problem is since
they're limited in calling witnesses
they're limited and have to ask for
permission about who they can ask for
and even what to ask and and say etc so
this is a chance for it to be made clear
that this has been an exercise in
hearsay in gossip in rumor and that's
what the American people have seen as
well and they realize
they don't like that at all so this is
of course what mansplaining is arguably
is is patronizing a woman did talking to
her and treating her as though she's a
child and yet that's exactly what meloni
ended up doing while complaining about
taylor is that you know talking to her
as though she was harmed we saw this
with you of anna [ __ ] as well talking
to her as though she was a you know a
soft little petal you know a Wallflower
in the corner and that you know sorry
you had to endure that this is again
another powerful woman she knows what
she's doing I don't think her feelings
were hurt
and by the way Taylor and others you
know they're talking this way to
virtually everyone and the fact is if
we're in the arena we've got we're gonna
be treated equally and that was the
crime so then Maloney through this
process besides just then treating her
like an infant who takes her by the hand
holding her hand like a little girl
taking her along about I mean it is that
is the sexism that is the insult whereas
all the men the male witnesses face the
same thing and nobody was worried about
their mental state though it's exactly
right really one of the most patronizing
things I can imagine it is but they
Bruce thanks for pointing that out they
meant it to be about sexism but I think
it's turning around on them very hardly
right it tells you more about them it
does good to see you tonight
thanks so much check out get Tammy
bruised two episodes out every Tuesday
on Fox Nation reason alone the subscribe